see garrett cole is towing that slab
into boogie down bronx here on a tuesday
night this will be his 15th start on the
year and the rest of the numbers are
just fantastic especially to 12 walks
let's see if they get two there's one on
to first
and the throw pulls void off the bag but
a nice play by clever toys
good range from gleber deep in the hole
and dj's right there there's just not
enough time to turn it as you see dj
tries to and can't get
anything on the throw but right here the
play is made
good range get the lead runner
[Applause]
lined into left field frazier puts it
away
and that'll do it no runs no hits no
errors one man left royals nothing
new york yankees coming back and they'll
be facing
brady singer who's coming off a start
that lasted just three innings because
of tightness in his right shoulder but
he stayed on schedule to make the start
tonight
and here's luke voight injuries have
derailed him so far
itching to get back and here he is
panning third in the yankee order
there it goes see you welcome back luke
voight one nothing eggs
oh what a way to come back luke voight
hits one to detroit a deep drive in the
left field seats
and the yankees take a one-nothing lead
think he's happy
i thought he wasn't anxious first pitch
he saw
fastball is grounded out to third and
gutierrez will get the force at second
base so
singer battles and the yankees get just
one on the voight home run
well here is another big home run hitter
who's not hitting
right-handed hunter dozier 1-2
swing in a miss high fastball 97 miles
an hour
royals go down an order against cole and
we will go to the bottom of the second
kyle higashioka will lead things off for
the yankees here in the bottom of the
second there was some question as to
whether or not he would be in the
starting lineup tonight to catch cole
with the way gary sanchez has been
swinging the bat lately
deep to left field dozier back
track wall see ya
and now that decision doesn't look so
questionable as higashiyoka
goes your two-nothing yanks kyle
hagasioka
the home run stroka and he's getting a
little higgy with it
off the end of the bat taylor comes up
and dives in center field and
takes a hit away from gardner hud was
telling you about
the royals production as far as
defensive run
saved in center field this year between
dyson
and michael a taylor they're getting the
job done we're saving the pitch count
for pitchers extra pitches and
saving runs look at the focus here
coming in tough ball to read
sure is fun especially when you can
slide on a wet turf like that
and he got him with a slider so a three
pitch strikeout against stanton
the yankees get one on the higashiyoka
home run look at that he's way up on the
bat
and that tells me he wants to get be
quick to that ball
the yankees will get one and the royals
will get one
nice job nice job yeah put it in play
get the ribby gives wit 41 ribbies 2-2
swing and i missed got him on the change
two-way a lot a lot of ball players from
the country
like tarzan or what oh yeah okay
foul tip and a strikeout that's singer
second
and there are two down in the third
inning yeah it's going to be big
al michaels nick cafardo the late
rider in boston brady singer has his
first 1-2-3 inning he has struck out
three
of the last four yankees here's ryan
o'hearn he's batting cleanup tonight
just called up from omaha
and there's a ball struck well deep
right field and that ball is gone
a home run for ryan o'hearn welcome back
and the royals
and yankees are tied at two well he was
red red hot at triple a and here he is
at yankee stadium he saw that short
porch to right
he said i can hit it over that fence
strike three gutierrez down looking
right in the top left part of the box
gutierrez doesn't like it
of all the things he learned last year
was that to never take his foot off of
the accelerator
that is a beautiful pitch now brady has
struck out three in a row
and four of the last five there's the
slider and
gardner swings right over it and now
brady singer has struck out four in a
row
got him in swing mode so that's
three consecutive walks after the two
strikeouts
and so giancarlo stanton's coming up
with the bases loaded
and two down as the royals make a call
to the bullpen
first pitch breaking ball and a slow
roller to third gutierrez steps on the
bag
and the inning comes to an end so just
barely fair
so says bill miller
hit sharply oh what a play
by lemayo to get taylor for the first
out
dj lemayo back at second base
where he excels makes that look easy
start low go high with the glove and
pick it
swing and a miss two away
gary cole in good shape here pitch count
wise in the sixth we'd love to get this
out quickly
and he does with a fly ball to shallow
left frazier comes on makes the play
and cole is retired nine in a row after
the home run allowed to o'hern
strike three gutierrez down looking
go ahead run at second base quick trip
to the mound by boom who's going to ask
him
what do you have left cole sets deals
got him 100 miles an hour on what will
be his final pitch of the night
impressive looks like they'll check coal
now for
any foreign substances and we'll come
back and show you what they do
and all the missed opportunities for the
yankees early in this game is really
kind of lingering drill deep to left
field
there it goes
see ya know the empire saying it's still
in play as boyd is hustling to third
he'll make it with a triple
and now he's gonna confer with the other
umpires
i thought that was out let's see if they
agree
now you're gonna have to um you know
wonder is that interference
what would that have been out and
they're gonna keep it as a triple
and a nice return for void a walk triple
and a home run
in his first game off the il that one
gets away
from sal perez scoring easily this time
away to the yankees lead three to two
the yankees will bring three infielders
in
there's the ground ball right spot the
game is tied
and in the dirt so ryan o'hearn is safe
royals are hoping for more in this
inning now dyson pulls it on the ground
and the play will be at the plate carlos
santana with a head first slide
and the royals lead for the first time
tonight
and dozier hits it to center field that
is down for a base hit
here comes o'hearn and the royals take a
5-3
lead with a three-run eighth inning
dozier again
started to run and that's back through
the middle dyson scores
and the royals have four in the eighth
inning
so lemay one for three with a walk
high fly deep right does your back
track wall see ya two-run home run for
lemayo
yankees climbing back in it's 6-5 royals
they're going to intentionally walk
sanchez
to get to brett gardner gardner pops it
up
gutierrez onto the grass and the royals
take game one